قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو ان بلاده ستفعل كل ما يلزم لحمايه
نفسها سواء تم التوصل الى اتفاق مع ايران
ام لا واضاف نتنياهو في مستهل الجلسه
الاسبوعيه لحكومته ان اسرائيل لن تلتزم
باي تسويه يتم التوصل اليها مع ايران
بحثنا بتوسع مواضيع عده في مقدمتها ايران
وقد اكدت لوزير الخارجيه التعاون
المخابرات والعسكري بين اسرائيل وامريكا
وكت له موقفنا الدائم من ان العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لن تمنعها من
الاستمرار في مشروعها النووي وستتيح لها
دخل اموال بكميات ضخمه الى المنظمات
الارهابيه التي تعمل برعايتها في الشرق
الاوسط وحول اسرائيل وان اي تسويه مع
ايران لن تكون ملزمين بها وبالاتفاق او
بدونه سنواصل كل ما يلزم من اجل حمايه
اسرائيل
معنا منا طهران علي اكبر داريني الباحث
المتخصص في الدراسات الايرانيه
الامريكيه سيد علي اكبر كيف تجد تصريحات
المرشد الاعلى السيد خمينائي في سياقها
الحالي وما يتم تسريبه عما جرى من لقاءات
غير مباشره في عمان بالاضافه الى مؤشرات
اخرى ترتبط بالملف النووي الايراني
المرشد الاعلى في ايران لم يستبعد امكانيه
التوصل الى اتفاق سواء كانت احياء اتفاق
النووي القديم او التوصل اتفاق اخر اذا
ابقى الابواب مفتوحه ولكنه اوضح بان
الصناعه النوويه الايرانيه يجب ان لا تلمس
ان تبقى اي ان ايران دوله على وشك ان تصبح
نوويه ولابد ان تبقى قوه على وشك ان تكون
قوه نوويه اذا فقدراتها الان بقى عليها
فقط ايام تبقى مده ايام فاذا قرات ايران
ان تطور سلاحا نوويا فان بامكانها ان تنتج
ما يكفي من
رانيا مخصب خلال ايام وبالتالي فهذا
هذا ينبغي يبقى كما هو كعنصر ردع
ولكن الحقيقه هي هي ان اتفاق 2015
الواقع في الحقيقه اصبح ميتا وان رغم ان
الجانب بين ليله علان ذلك لانه ليس
امامهما خيار افضل اذا ايران توجد قائد
الطريقه الحوار مفتوحا مع التاكد عن قدرته
الردعيه تبقى قويه ولا مسافه بها
ولن تتعاون الايران مع الوكاله الدوليه
طارق الطاقه الذريه بما يتجاوز الضمانات
الضمانات المذكوره هذه هي قاله المرشد
الاعلى النيران
هو الاتفاق لا لا
قدرات ايران انه اذا بد ان تبقى دون تغيير
سيد علي ذكرت مجموعه من النقاط الهامه
ابدا معك باشارتك بان ايران
منفتحه اما بالعوده الى الاتفاق السابق او
اتفاق جديد هل لك ان تشرح لان هناك حديث
ان ايران ترفض الحديث عن اتفاق مؤقت
نعم كانت هناك بعض النقاشات الخاصه بشكل
غير مباشر بين ايران والولايات المتحده
وقامت بها عمان بالدوره الوسيط
ولكن اي من ايران او الولايات المتحده لم
لم يؤكذا بانه
الاتفاق ما يمكن قوله في هذا الوقت من
الزمان انه ربما قد كنا كامكانيه تحقيق
تقدم نحو وتفهم ليس اتفاق تفاهم بان ايران
ستستعيد
اموالها
وتخفف العقوبات عليها لقاء قيامه ايران
بتقديم ضمانات بانها لن تتوجه نحو
تطوير السلاح نووي او زياده مستوى تقسيم
هذا لا يمكن استبعادهم ولكن الحقيقه هي ان
الولايات المتحده غير راغبه ولا تريد
احياء الاتفاق النووي القديم ان اداره
بايدن
اوضحت بان بين احياء اتفاق النووي ليس ضمن
جدول اعمالها بل انها هذه الاداره تسعى
الى الاستفزاز والتشجيع الاضطرابات في
ايران وتشجيع المعارضه الايرانيه وهذا
طبعا جعل الوضع يتدهور في اتفاق 2015 هو
هذا اتفاق يعود الى فتره
النظام احاديه
عندما كانت متحده القوه الوحيده اما الان
فقد تغير العالم العالم يتوجه الان الى
تعدديه الاخطاء لنركز سيد علي اكبر تغير
العالم والشرق الاوسط تغيره وايران تغيرت
واسرائيل زادت تهديداتها ضد ايران سيد علي
اكبر
لنركز على محاوله فهم ما التصور الايراني
بناء على ما قاله المرشد بالانفتاح على
اتفاق هناك من يقول بان عندما تتحدث ايران
بالانفتاح على اتفاق فهو وفق الرؤيه
الايرانيه وليس وفق رؤيه اخرى سواء
امريكيه او اوروبيه ما الرؤيه الاوروبي
الايرانيه
لاتفاق غير الاتفاق السابق
اي اتفاق جديد
لابد ان يقدم ما يكفي من تاكيدات وضمانات
بين ايران ستستطيع ان تستفيد اقتصاديا
ولابد ان تحصل ايران على التطمينات
وتاكيدات قويه بين حصل على فوائد اقتصاديه
وكما في 2015 ايران لن تقوم بتصديره اي من
مواد
وهذا يعني المواد
الايرانيه
في داخل اراضي ايران لانه اذا حصل اي
اتفاق
وسحب الامريكان من الانسحاب مره اخرى
انذاك ستستطيع ايران ان تعيد العمل
ببرنامجها بشكل سريع
وبالتالي
المفتاح لابد ان يبقى بين ايادي ايرانيه
واذا ما وافقوا على هذه الشروط فهناك
امكانيه للتواصل للاتفاق النقطه الثالثه
المهمه كانت ان ان الملف النووي في
الوكاله الدوليه لايران ينبغي ان يغلق اذا
قبلت هذه الشروط فعل الارجح اتفاق اذا كان
امريكا مستعده له من طهرا علي اكبر داريني
الباحث المتخصص للدراسات الايرانيه
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك